The following is a production of Frankie Freitas and the Internet Museum of Holography.
Hello everyone, this is Frankie Freitas, and welcome to HoloTalk for the week of May 10th, 1999.
Our guest this week is Sam Savage.
And Sam is lead engineer at Lucent Technology at Bell Labs.
And Sam's going to come on and speak with us a little bit about how we can run these laser diodes and laser diode modules inexpensively without spending a lot of money on expensive power supplies to run these things.
And not only inexpensively, but more importantly, uh now that we're able to do very beautiful holograms using these diodes, especially the higher powered ones, such as the recent test with the 35 millilite, but also consistent results.
This is one of the things that running the diodes off the batteries has not been able to provide us.
And that's consistent results.
If you're running that, especially the higher powered ones where they're drawing more current, and you're running that diode uh for several hours to do a shot.
Well, when you get ready to do the second shot, you're not still putting the same amount of power into that diode and your exposure time is going to change.
It's very difficult to get consistent results if you're going to run these higher power diodes off of batteries, unlike the uh little laser pointers which seem to run forever on the batteries.
Uh so what we're trying to do right now is get it to the point where we can inexpensively run them and get consistent results, which means you can leave that laser diode on twenty-four hours a day, and every shot that you do with it, you're going to have the same result in the same exposure time because you're still feeding the same amount of power in.
Now you can go out and buy a very expensive driver.
I can I've seen them for over a thousand dollars to run these things, uh, but we're looking at doing it for maybe about twenty dollars or thirty dollars uh where you can have that something that you can plug into the wall, run your higher power laser diode module off of, and forget about it.
So Sam Savage is going to come on and give us a little bit of an idea on how to do that and where we are with that right now.
Now, HoloTalk's getting ready to wind down for the season.
If you know this is our second season, and we're we run the same season that the television shows do.
So we run from the fall until the spring, and when the TV shows go into their summer reruns, HoloTalk goes into its reruns as well.
So we're looking at basically the last shows that are coming up.
Now next week is going to be a special show.
I'm already thinking about some interesting things to do next year with HoloTalk.
And one of the things that I've come up with is to do special holography broadcasts on the internet to our overseas friends, such as Germany, uh Spain, Japan, uh South American countries, and a number of other different countries, but in their native language, so that their educators and their students at the schools or at home, if they have an internet connection, they can log on and they can listen to a special broadcast specifically for them in their own language and learn about lasers and holograms in the process.
It's sort of like a technological evangelism.
So next week we're going to do the first broadcast in this series, and it's going to be going to Columbia, South America.
And I met a student in one of my workshops that I ran over at the Science Center that I'm involved with over at Lehigh University.
And I sat down and I spoke with him and I asked him, Would you come in and do some translations?
And we'll do a special broadcast for your country.
He's from Colombia.
So we've got a press release uh ready.
We're going to send that down to the major newspapers in Colombia.
Let them know through their media outlets that the students and educators, researchers, and the general population can log on and learn about lasers and holograms during a special broadcast in their native language along with English.
So Andres Munoz will be in the studio with me, translating what I'm saying into Spanish for our South American friends.
And next year I look forward to doing quite a few of these broadcasts.
They won't be the regular weekly HoloTalk broadcasts after this first initial one next week.
We'll have special pages for them to go to, and we'll just continue with our regular programming every week on the regular Holo Talk page.
So I'm really looking forward to that as well.
So let's move on to Sam Savage interview.
Sam came into my studio for a workshop several months ago.
He was very intrigued by creating holograms using the laser diodes, especially after a number of different people had told him it was impossible to do.
And we've been working together, and Sam's been very helpful working out power requirements for driving these uh diodes.
As you may remember, I've tried a number of different experiments on my own, and they worked okay, power supplies that drive the little walkmans and things like that, and just running a laser uh module directly off of that.
And some results turned out okay, some results uh didn't even turn out at all.
But basically what's happening is uh Sam has come up with a way to uh provide very safe, controlled power that's inexpensive.
And the whole point of this is to be able to be just working with these as easily as we work with a helium neon laser, which is plug it in the wall, turn it on, and work with it, and you pretty much have consistent results every time you're working with it.
Especially with the higher power diodes because they really do pull a lot of uh power, uh current out of the uh batteries that we use.
Because I'm still I still used uh three 1.5 volt AA batteries.
But if I were to work with that and do another one later on in the evening, hours later, I'd have to adjust my exposure times because there's less power going into the module.
So Sam's going to come on the show and we're going to talk a little bit about power.
And slowly but surely we are working out every detail of making semiconductor holography a reality and a viable, a viable reality for making holograms.
So here's a quick message from my studio, and after the message is over, we're going to go right into the interview with Sam Savage Wheels.
So I will say thank you for tuning in, and I hope you tune in each and every week for the rest of the season.
We probably have about two or three shows to go, and then we'll be on reruns for the summer, but we'll be back in the fall with brand new topics, brand new guests, and you can bet your bottom dollar some pretty exciting information to start off that first Holo Talk show in the fall.
So I'll see you next week with our special broadcast to Columbia, South America.
Would you like to make your own one of a kind hologram and learn how you can start making holograms on your own at the same time?
You can do this and much more by attending one of Frank the Greatest's holography workshops.
From beginner to advance, Frank's got a workshop that's just right for you.
From single afternoon, evening, or weekend introductory workshops to Wednesday evening five-week complete courses.
And don't forget his newest workshop, Laser Pointer Holography.
Located just off the Northeast Extension of the Pennsylvania Turnpike and Interstate 78.
The studio is a quick nonstop drive from the New York, Philadelphia, and Baltimore, Washington DC areas.
For more information, call the studio's toll-free hotline at 1-800-458-3525 and begin your own journey with holography today.
That's 1-800-458-3525 for more information on attending Frank DeFreyda's holography workshop today.
Hi, is this Ann?
Hi, this is Frank DeFraze.
How are you?
Hi.
Happy Mother's Day.
Thank you.
Is Sam in today?
Yeah, hold on a second.
Hello buddy.
Hi Sam, how are you?
Pretty good, but I just rest a little bit.
How are you doing?
Okay.
I thought we'd start off with just uh getting a little bit of information and what's some of your thoughts about these diodes and how can we run these diodes inexpensively without having to buy very expensive power supplies.
Well uh if you if you supply the power to the data that the DA requires if you have a power supply and the supply power to a battery is allowed to filter and deliver and right potential to that dough then it should be uh that should cut out the need for expensive drivers and stuff like that.
There's a couple different ways of running these laser diodes.
Number one is just buy a raw diode and supply the necessary power at the exact specifications of the diode.
And and the other way is to buy the laser diode with the little micro driver inside and run it off of batteries.
Do you see one advantage over the other?
Oh yeah, by by yeah, uh yeah, uh sure.
If you if you buy the diode raw as it is and have a supply driving that, like with your batteries with but the thing about the about using the diode and a power supply, uh the best thing is a battery and keep the power supply on the battery.
I see.
Because the batteries you may after a while may fluctuate, you know, the voltage may drop but it will over time.
But what with a battery and a and a power supply with which had to be doesn't happen to be that expensive a cheap power supply on a battery, allowing the battery to filter out that supply with any kind of noise that it may be coming from the uh the power supply.
And that that way is it's a lot cheaper than uh if you bought a driver and everything else and the thing he thinks w w with the driver and all that.
Well that can amount to a little bit of money, you know.
Yeah.
But still still keeping away below what would cost for Heeley or any other gas laser.
Now the battery acts as a pretty good filter then, right?
The battery is a excellent filter.
You can look at a battery a and you would look at electrolytic capacitor, okay.
And that uh which could be uh filter all the time on the with the battery would be complete completely filled a much better filter than uh the electrolytic capacitor.
But theoretically you can look at the uh battery as an electrolytic capacitor in in in a sense a filtering.
Okay.
But they could the back of the electroder capacitor characteristically it's the same as the battery.
Other words if you have a uh electrolytic capacitor that uh that is uh working voltage say uh seventy five volt, but you're not only gonna put it across six volts, four volts or five volts or three volts.
It's gonna charge up the three volts, although it's got a working capacity of seventy five.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
D the it would do the same work at three volts and it would at seventy five volts.
The properties of that capacitor would do the same thing that would at the a lower voltage.
Now you wouldn't go above that voltage, uh seventy five volts but would that that would damage the capacitor.
Mm-hmm.
And so the same is with the battery and and looking at the electrolytic, uh looking at the same as electrolytic capacitor, the the battery will do the same thing.
Now it doesn't mean it does not mean that you can uh that you have to charge a battery if it's twelve volts or six volts uh you don't have to charge it at that rate.
If I if you got a a six volt battery, say like a a lead acid cell uh battery is is really uh is really good for uh filtering and and uh keeping a good charge.
So if you have a twelve volt battery the the uh shortcut thing, yeah uh electrolytic is seventy five volts.
In other words you don't have to charge the twelve volt battery at twelve volts.
Mhm.
Okay.
You don't want to go above that or you know, over its threshold but you can go below that.
Mhm.
And it will maintain its charge at that voltage that you devoted your charging that.
And you have a lot of capacity there.
And best thing of all, you have the filtering that you need.
If you got a a power supply, uh if you have a power supply that's linear instead of you know switching.
Yeah.
The the although if you do have a switching power supply the the battery will filter.
Mm.
But I don't think I would take a chance with it on a raw diode.
Yeah.
Uh but supplying one of the modules it would be Oh yeah it'd be fine, yeah.
Now here's here's a little idea I have.
We have the uh thirty five milliwatt uh diode module that we've been running.
I did the holograms off of the um uh module at four point five volts.
So if I went out and I got a six volt battery and I drained that battery down so it was below the six volts, actually below four point five.
And then I got one of the inexpensive chargers that you can get for running Walkman's and send that into that battery at four point five volts and then run the module off of that battery, we'd be in pretty good shape.
Yeah, you sh w you would.
You you can charge let's say you needed fo you're saying you need a four point five for the the the driver.
Mm-hmm.
Well I I would charge the battery a little bit more than four point five because you can have a drop you'd have to take care of the drop where it maintains four point five.
And okay I could go up I'd go up another at least a half volt and uh charge it that way and that way that that would float at the at the level you want it to float at to like you want to let it float at four point five, that's what it'll do.
Mm-hmm that and also uh take care of the filtering that you need.
Now could that charger be left on that battery continuously?
Sure.
Now we we try to do this real real simple, uh we wanna get into real a lot of theory and all this other for people understand but uh if you have a six volt battery okay and uh what you could do is put a six volt lamp above in series with that uh charger and the battery.
You can notice the lamp w it would be real bright if it's low charge.
As as the battery begins to charge, the light will go dimmer and dimmer, means there's no current being pulled from the charger to the battery.
I see.
And when it when it gets almost out, it will uh uh you can say it's charged.
Mm-hmm.
Now would you leave the charger on there or take it off?
I would leave it I would leave it on because you also now you have you can always watch that the lamb also protected too.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, so you can uh monitor it monitor the the uh how your battery's doing by just looking at the lamp.
Six old lamp.
If you wanted to charge that battery at four point five volts, you'd get a four point five volt lamp, right?
Well you don't uh uh no, you can get a uh I I still go with six still fire to six volt, but it won't be as bright.
I see, okay.
Uh as long as you got current flowing through there, that thing's that's still gonna be uh that that would six volts, yeah, that that would still you still get some light from that.
Now in in essence what the battery's going to do is it's going to filter out any noise that's coming from from the A C line, right?
Any any well, any noise that's not been power supply that's not filtered, that's it goes through A C goes through your uh power supply, then you're gonna what it's gonna do, the transformer you're gonna either gonna step up or step it down.
In this case you'd be stepping it down, then it's gonna be g go through a bridge rectifier in most cases.
With the rectifier is gonna be changing that to that A C to pulse A in D C.
Now we're not pure D C yet, okay?
And if your power spider's got filters in there, that's gonna smooth out the best it can the pulsating D C that it's changing from A C to D C but it's actually changing from A C to pulsating D C.
Now a pulse fate and D C without being filtered to any kind of circuit is A C.
So the pulsation is a sort by the uh output capacitors in the in your in your church in your a power supply.
Now if any noise gets by that if they sell some ripple uh pulsation in that D C well then the battery would take care of it.
Hmm.
So it's uh a very good filter.
Now it's standard is it's an outstanding filter.
And any type of um spikes that would come through the AC line or any types of uh slight variations, like if someone in the neighborhood turns their air conditioner on or the refrigerator kicks on and off, the battery the the diode running off of that six volt battery at charged at four point five volts will actually uh take all that out as well.
Right it's uh it's just filter out and day out.
But if the A C fluctuates and changes, uh what that means your y your your D C is going to change.
Uh unless your power supply is regulated how they regulate it.
I mean if it's regular that means it's not going to go above what you what you need, okay.
Okay.
But the uh if it's not re very good regulated then you get spikes.
But yeah spike is gonna get out through the the on the outside of power supply.
Yeah.
And but that spike or uh dip in the in is going to be a sewed by the battery.
Yeah how would someone hook this up?
Uh let's say I have one of the uh A C to D C uh converters that we run the walkmans off of some one of those that you can buy over at Best Buy or other electronic or stereo store to run your cassette decks or portable walkmans.
And they have uh uh the different adjustments for three volts, four point five volts, nine volts.
So let's say we buy one of those.
They're they're relatively inexpensive, maybe about ten dollars.
We set that to four point five volts.
We've got our six volt battery and we want to put the four point five volts into the six volt battery and we want to run the module off of the battery.
Do we just take the wires and attach it to the battery and then take the wires from the module and also attach that to the battery?
Sure, you s you take your power supply and put it across your batteries.
Yeah.
Okay.
You come to the terminals roughly off to the same terminal and go to your your module.
Hm.
So just is that just it that's the you know what you're doing, you're looking at it as a filter, output filter.
Yes.
What that battery is what you're acting more as you're just looking at it as output filter.
Yeah it's actually acting more as a filter than it is the the supply you're not really the batteries one reason batteries uh the main reason batteries are used in an electronic circuit not just it's not just for reserve power but it's for filtrization.
Oh I see.
If you got the if you've got a uh if you got a circuit that you uh it acts as a filter and acts as a battery back as a backup in case you lose uh an A C an A C say or something.
So it's they're sitting online.
Now some circuits depending on in uh you know how much load you have and you know the batteries may not be uh the matter be be fitting in the in a circuit as a reserve not cut in, you know.
Yeah.
Until you get a low voltage disk in the way until you get a power uh outage and then the battery's uh cut in.
Mm-hmm and but most cases the batteries are sitting on the line on the output of the line the power supply sitting there charging and filtering.
Hmm the fluctuations in the AC and if you have an inductive load, okay an inductive load that would take care of the uh the the the noise that may be coming from equipment, you know, there's some of the uh the the equipment can cause uh you load equipment can cause noise and also i i it would filter that out.
Hm.
So this this is looking pretty good and very inexpensive is that the whole we can we can get into some talk about some real elaborate regulated and all this stuff drivers re but we want to since we've gone to the diode and not dealing with healing neons anymore.
Expensive uh we have done holograms, if we're gonna go the trying to make this thing as an expensive we can well then everything has to be inexpensive.
Yeah.
And we have to make it uh at least inexpensive dice well we gotta you know uh make inexpensive fire supplies if everybody wants to be able to do it.
Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm we can you can go as a live as you want to make more and it's it's like uh you can go just the ex uh you know expensive you want to get but we can do something that's cheap that it will do the job well I think that's the route we ought to try to go.
Absolutely.
And it it's always you can always run the diode module off of regular double A batteries or whatever, but the only problem with that is the longer that that diode's on, the less voltage is going into it and you're getting less power as time goes on.
That could you know uh that could d affect the diode depending on the diode that diode.
Uh the battery at say let's say that uh the battery for the let's say the the current drain uh the load of a uh a thirty five milliwatt uh laser diet is set forty five milliamps.
Mhm.
Well then it won't take long, you know, too long for uh that if you just put the battery on it without even keeping it uh floating, the voltage is gonna drop.
Yeah.
And the high like the five hundred milliwatt, that was around over a thousand uh milliamp 'cause you know you're talking about uh one amp.
So, you know on the batteries that ain't gonna last long at all.
I mean that's so that's gonna drop and that won't be enough for the diode and that could cause uh heating problem with the diode.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, on the five milliwatt there's no problem, okay.
It had a pretty good range there on that five milliwatt uh corner, you know.
Yeah.
At a pretty good range you could run a good while and and you're w I notice you do charging yours with a uh solar cell.
Yeah, yeah.
So but you can but when you start getting up into more power on a diode, you know, increasingly we go on up up in power, well that's the f I square R, you know, and that's that's uh uh or you times that's gonna be more watts it's gonna be more current pulling uh uh it's gonna require more current to operate.
And that's why it it's a good idea to have a battery with a charger sitting on it.
And perfectly the uh the lead acid cell.
Like a lawnmower battery.
Yeah, it's uh uh one that's a lead acid.
Yeah.
I'm not sure about motorcycle batteries.
I'm not sure if they're twelve volts or six volt but I think the lawnmower batteries are like six volt.
Well I I think you can buy uh you can buy these uh lead acid cells that's pretty good amp hours on it and uh at two volts.
And you can put used to be uh maybe you can buy some that the one point five of the sale.
Mm.
And then you have a lot to deal with, you know, you play with uh they're lead acid, a lot of capacity and enough that expensive.
So uh there's some places around to have that you can get these.
I know Gates uh makes uh a lead acid cell uh about three inches in diameter, you know, about uh six inches high or something like that.
Mhm.
But it's got pretty good capacity and it's lead acid.
And uh you can string them up to the uh the voltage that you need and put your charge across it.
And if you wind up with more voltage than you need you can just uh you you can just drop it.
You just uh you just drop your figure out your voltage drop, the voltage you need, figure that voltage drop, then you determine that from your uh the amount of current it's gonna be using and then you can determine uh with Home's law determine uh what kind of r y resistance you need to drop that voltage.
And just put a resistor right in line there.
Right, exactly.
Yeah.
Well it seems pretty easy.
And why why go out 'cause I've seen some of the power supplies for the diodes that are running over a thousand dollars.
Well, absolutely.
The uh the drivers sometimes they they've uh are are very expensive, but the uh I believe we can uh we can do it a lot cheaper.
We've made it so uh inexpensive, especially with your uh shoe box philography.
I mean, my goodness.
And it's uh dropped it uh for you know, the the cost has come way down why you so a long time ago it used to be.
We made making history and uh making pioneers.
So we might well get make the power supply along with the diode, you know, make it all cheap so people be able to to do it.
Yeah.
You have that hologram of the angel now.
What do you think of that?
That's an example that uh that is that is actually breathtaking to know that was taken with a uh a thirty five milliwatt diode and a helium uh neon uh couldn't do as good a job as that.
It's really unbelievable.
Actually, I know it's hard for folks to see that on the internet on a picture.
I've taking a have you taken a picture of it, but actually seeing this hologram, uh, it's it's actually breathtaking.
It's unbelievable the depth with the you know, the wings and all that.
It's just it's just unbelievable.
It's real bright.
Uh it's it's amazing.
It's really amazing.
Well, Sam, I want to thank you for taking the time today to come on the show.
And don't forget to log on tonight.
It'll be on by midnight tonight, which is Sunday, and I'll be talking with you, I guess, a little bit later in the week.
Thank you very much for I'm glad to have a I'm not too good at this talking, so uh special ideas, but uh thanks for having me on.
All right, Sam.
Bye.
Talk to you later.